speaking of is across world and present
opportunity to thank you so we consider
the following question so that want amel
for distributed computing and we know
some positive answers in some models of
distributed computing for example for
anonymous networks faulty networks or
for quantum multi-party communication
complexity but in the classical
distributed the computing community to
other models are extremely popular
recently the conscious model and the
local model and I will explain these two
models in the next slides and these two
models have been studied in the quantum
setting in 2009 2014 but unfortunately
the results were mostly negative has
been shown that it's impossible to
attain a speed up using quantum
computation this model for many
important problems like computing the
shortest passes or computing minimum
spanning trees and but recent work has
shown that for all their problems you
can obtain speed ups and today I will
like to talk about these results so let
me describe the model
congest model and local model the
classical setting first so it's really a
basic one of the boss the most basic
settings in distributive computing
everything is non faulty non-anonymous
and synchronous so you have a network of
n nodes represented as network as a
graph like this and all nodes of
distinct identifiers and each node
initially knows only the ideas of its
neighbors and we assume that they know
also the total number of nodes so for
example not for only know that it is
connected to 1 3 & 6 but does not know
anything else about the topology of the
graph and communication is synchronous
and between Nate between neighbor
adjacent nodes so at each round one
message is sent through each age in each
direction so for example at 1 1 all the
node exchange when we say JH then there
it local
computation we don't care about the cost
it can be exponential time we don't care
and then another round of communication
then local computation and then again
communication and so on and we care
about the round complex this number of
runs needed to do the computation and
then there is an important parameter
which is a site of the message and he'll
come to to model in the conscious model
we assume that each message is short
concretely logan bits wide log n because
it's exactly what you need in order to
encode 1 ID while in the local model
there is no restriction on the size of
each message and both model are very
interesting and well studied in the
classical setting for example local
model corresponds situation where
communication is very fast and cheap and
what you care is really the number of
rounds needed to reach the conclusion of
your computation ok I know the quantum
settings are easy now we can send
quantum bits instead of classical bits
so as it means that each nodes the
quantum processor and message quantum
bits and so there's a chapter the edge
correspond to quantum channels ok and we
are again interested in the run
complexity and get the two models of
quantum conscious muddle with small
quantum messages and a local model with
no restriction on the size of each
message is there any questions on the
model
okay so let's first describe this
advantage first advantage quantum
advantage the congest model it's a
recent work with Rick and we have shown
that the diameter of the network can be
computed in square root and rounds in
the quantum setting while classically
you need n rounds so is give you a
quadratic gap when the diameter is
constant what is the diameter so here we
consider only undirected and weighted
graphs the diameter of the graph is
defined as a maximum distance between
two nodes so for example in this graph
the diameter is 4 because the 2 most
remote nodes are F and G and 1 2 3 4 and
the diameter can be rewritten as the
maximum eccentricity eccentricity where
the eccentricity of a node is defined as
a maximum distance between this node and
another node of the graph we will use
this characterization
so now I will define a basic but very
fundamental a classical distributed
algorithm for computing distances so
assume that you want to compute the
distance a from node 1 this can be done
by using the breadth first search
algorithm it's a very simple so first
the source of not 1 send the message to
all its neighbors then all the node that
receive a message know that they are
distance 1 at the second round all the
nodes at distance 1 send a message to
their neighbor and at the end of run to
all the nodes that received a message
for the first time at run to know that
they are at distance 2 to the update the
distance and we continue like this until
everybody knows its distance and of
course the complexity is precisely the
eccentricity of the source which is a
bounded by D because this diameter is
the maximum eccentricity so to summarize
this algorithm enables you for one fix
not you to compute all the distance from
you I mean you can compute a new problem
of the diameter very easily and stop
when you reach such a second you can
propagate back the information to tell
everybody that you can stop it's a good
question but it's not very important for
today stick
okay and then so you can propagate in
the around and there and if you
propagate back the informations then you
can compute the maximum of this distance
of the eccentricity the cost will be a
big ole often but the point is that
computing the diameter that is the
maximum eccentricity it's much more
complicated you need a linear number of
round even if the diameter if the
diameter is constant it's a little bit
surprising it has been shown fairly
recently and we have shown that actually
can do better in the quantum settings so
here is a detail the computation of the
diameter classically as I said it's and
you have an upper bound and a lower bond
o n and quantumly you have an upper
bound of square root n D so in
particular when V is sub linear the
complexity is sudden near here and when
these constants give you a square root n
which is quadratically faster than the
classical and we also have some lower
bounds this one square root n plus D and
another one which is tight but it's
conditional under the condition that
it's it's all done Z for quantum
algorithms that use only few memory a
poly log limp memory and or algorithm
actually use on the poly log and I
should mentioned that all this bound in
the web on the classical in the quantum
ones are obtained by proving reduction
from the two-party communication
complexity of the disjointness function
and I should also mention that there are
very recent result by the Frederic
inertia will actually improve this in
conditioner lower bound to this
and from now I would like to describe
the Obama okay so we want to compute the
diameter let's consider the decision
version of this problem I give you an
integer D and I ask you if the diameter
is larger than the or not of course if
you can solve this version you can solve
the original version so we have to
decide if there exists a vertex u such
that the eccentricity of U is larger
than D so it's a search problem so the
intuition is let's try to to use global
search
so concretely you consider this function
f defined on the set of vertices with
value 1 if the eccentricity is larger
than D and you want to find a u such
that F U is equal to 1 and we know by
grover search that is can be done using
square root n calls to an Oracle
evaluating the function f we all know
the details of growver algorithm so you
apply the grover operator square root n
time and you Monsieur and the growth of
operator apply an Oracle
Adamo gates phase gate and other markets
and the point here is that the only
point of growver circuit here that
depends on the function f is a call to
the Urraco
all the other thing are independent of
the function so now of strategies as
follows we take one arbitrary node of
the network a leader say is a node with
a smallest ID and we ask the leader to
implement this circuit the whole circuit
so another leader can do this locally
because it's independent on the network
you can do this and this also locally
but it cannot implement the Oracle
purely locally because the Oracle depend
on the function f and f is essentially
the eccentric depend on the eccentricity
which depend on the whole network so the
idea is that anytime the leader will
need to implement one call to the Oracle
the leader will communicate with the
other nodes to simulate the
Erico so the total complexity will be
square root n the number of repetition
times the cost the number of rounds
needed to implement one call to this
Oracle and now I will explain how to
implement this efficiently
go to the Oracle okay so the Oracle
should compute the function f so this
means should compute the eccentricity
and of course in superposition and I
will explain how to do it on this
example with the leader being the node a
initially the not a as a state I want to
create this the first step is what I
call broadcast as a state so what do I
mean so first not a introduced one
register here with a zero initially at
zero and the node a apply one see not
copy the information of Yui here
I do not a sent the second register to
see the register to the next node now do
not see will introduce three registers
from T not operation and distribute is
three registers to eight children
PC and E and you continue like this okay
each time you take introduced register
you apply cenotes and you distribute to
your children it's what I call broadcast
the state okay at the end you're paying
this it calls the eccentricity of a
exactly which is upper bounded by T okay
so now the next step we there is not
implement the classical protocols for
computing the eccentricity I mentioned a
few minutes ago that this can be done in
dear on computing the eccentricity of
one vertex the node applies this
protocol and we get the eccentricity
here so this part is completely trivial
or very subtle depending on how you
think about it you can
think of this you have a classical
protocol you can think of they are of
the classical protocol as a secret
classical secret and then you can
consider a reversible version of it and
then a quantum version of it and this
quantum version of it will do exactly
this will pre compute the eccentricity
in superposition so we will be able to
do it in exactly the same complexity
rods and then finally you revert the
step one which you raised all these
intermediate register and you get
exactly what you wanted total complexity
is a big off essentially because you can
compute one eccentricity graphically in
a big wad
they won't release fro they don't throw
away the other no I mean you have a you
know class yeah the same issue will
arrive in a classical protocol okay
classical protocol will receive many
most besides and will do something and
it's something with our the end in able
to get the eccentricity and then with
your mechanical conversion of this
classical protocol into a quantum proto
so we don't really have to think about
all these issues they are deals by a
classical protocol for computing the
eccentricity to think carefully about
what class call protocol me
okay so to summarize so we have a
quantum search that enables you to solve
this problem using square root and calls
of black box and no strategy to ask a
leader to simulate that and the leader
can do everything except the call for
the Urraco and each call for the Oracle
is implemented by using the quantum
version of the classical algorithm for
computing the eccentricity so the
overall complexity square root n time
large D and with further work this can
be reduced to a square root nd with the
D inside the root maybe I can say one
word about that this is actually because
we have a stronger result here we used D
rounds to compute one eccentricity but
there is a stronger result that say that
in D runs you can compute D
eccentricities simultaneously so this
means that you can walk through the
browser search over groups of D vertices
which reduces the size of you of your
search space and put the D inside the
complex inside the square root in the
complex
okay so this give uses a powerbomb we
have the flu a bond of course upon
problem is to prove an unconditional
lower bound matching tight so you have
this bond which is better than this one
but still not tight another thing is
that over power bound is obtained by
showing out to implement quantum search
in the distributed setting it's a very
generic technique so it should have a
lot of applications okay and for example
recently we found two other applications
to design quantum distributed algorithm
for the old pair shortest path problem
and also triangle finding they are not
actually copy D trail because for all
pair shortest paths for example you need
to implement simultaneously and square
quantum distributed search in particular
you need to implement simultaneously and
square
checking procedures so you have to be
extremely careful about outward how to
balance the load of your message in
order to avoid congestion so it requires
a lot of subtle techniques from
classical distributed computing
so this was the first part of the talk
about the congested model we are shown
that quantum can be useful for some
problems now what about the local motors
so local model is different because
there is no restriction on the size of
each message so you want to compare a
number on the amount of quantum
communication and a number need amount
of classical communication it looks a
little bit more challenging in Prior
work we there was a computational
problem that can be solved in one round
in the quantum local model but requires
two runs classically and recently we
have shown that actually you can have a
much larger gap there is a computational
problem that can be solved in 2 rounds
quantum leap but requires a linear
number of rounds in the classical set I
will explain briefly this problem it's
based on the construction by beretta
toll dating back to 2009 I think many of
you know it because it was also used in
the resin result on quantum shallow
secretes this this thing can think as a
ring or a triangle so 5 n n multiple of
3 through seeing as a triangle with a
suicide each of length n over 3 each
corner gets a bit we have three corners
I get a bit as an input b1 b2 b3 and
each node will not put one bit this will
be the output of the problem and now
consider the following process the nodes
prepare the graph state corresponding to
the whole triangle and then all the
nodes which are not in the corner
Monsieur the a qubit of the graph state
in the X basis so they get one bit and
the output that bit so now each corner
node Bezier its qubit in the X basis if
the corresponding input bit is zero
otherwise multi-rate in the white qubit
in the white babies just give you a bit
and this bit is output
we know how to implement this process in
a shallow quantum circuit it's not
difficult to show that in the setting we
consider distributed computations this
can be done in two rounds essentially
each node has only to communicate with
these neighbors and get back some
information so to run for the first step
repairing the all graph state and you
don't need any communication for the
year for measuring and doing the output
you can do it in two runs in the quantum
setting but you can show that
classically any classical algorithms
that samples from the same distribution
might use at least n over six runs the
profits from the the paper by Barrett at
all it's fairly easy so if you have less
than n over six rounds essentially you
cannot gather at the same point two
input two input bits this means that
each output can only be an affine
function of the three input bits and you
can show it's not enough to sample from
this distribution okay so this give you
two rounds quanta quantumly and another
six round classical yes input bit a B 1
B 2 B 3 couples this node is a corner so
you look at its input and if the b2 is a
zero it measuring the X basis and if it
is the one it may be in the Y basis only
exception in the corner that follow a
different road depending on what they
receive as in
okay so we got the sister result I
mentioned before also the computational
problem is simulate the outcome
distribution of a measurement of a graph
state corresponding to the ring if you
remark actually or quantum algorithms as
a part of creating the graph state
actually requires it's two runs but only
very short messages one qubit per
message
you only need to share to send one qubit
and receive back one qubit so what we
get is actually a stronger statement and
separation between quantum congest and
classical local second remark is that
you can show similar separation for a
relation if you don't like distribution
you can either also separation for
relation and the third remark which more
interesting is that we can also get a
similar separation for something problem
without any input the previous version
we are three input b1 b2 b3 you can get
a version without input by taking b1 b2
b3 uniformly at random and it's
interesting because we don't know how to
prove the same result for shallow
circuits the conclusion we now know that
the quantum distributed distributed
algorithm can be faster than classical
distributed for several problems in both
the conscious motor and the local model
which are very important model in
computing and a few research directions
of first main one may be to construct
all the quantum distributed algorithm
for important problem this is actually I
think very interesting because this
poses a lot of new algorithmic
challenges because we really have to
focus on the run complexity it's a
little bit different from optimizing the
time context is a great complexity or
the communication complexity things that
we have done in the past 20 years it's
very different
second thing develop a new Lebon
techniques for quantum distributed
algorithm as I briefly mentioned for the
conscious model you can obtain some
bounds using two-party communication
complexity two-party quantum
communication
for the local model we don't know any
non-trivial oh and the third thing that
we considered here the conscious mode as
a local model but there are many other
models in distributed computing so we
can consider a quantum version of this
or their models and check if they are
more powerful than the classical version
for example this week we updated we
uploaded a new result that that the
distributed version of interactive
proofs and obviously quantum version and
we show that the quantum version can be
exponentially better than the classical
- okay that's all thank you
[Applause]
you think that some of these ideas can
be generalized to a paranoiac setting
yes of course I don't know I don't know
the answer but it's an important part of
research on classical distributed
computing to consider faulty cases or
cases where there are bad guys
adversary's cases where there are noise
so you can ask what is the power of
quantum is this settings I haven't
really considered that yet I don't think
so because if you kill one qubit you
lose all the quantum correlations so
it's probably
yes so quantum classically you know that
you were the best upper bound is n to
the one over three rounds it's a
classical and quantum that we get this n
to the one over four so it's an
improvement of the classical
the assumption is that the lower bound
holds for quantum any quantum algorithms
that use only a small amount of quantum
memory
holy log cubits of condiment
and quantum algorithm does use exactly
this this time it's tight for the for at
least for all kinds of a quantum alerts
not
[Applause]